Thank you for joining us today.
Let's listen in.
This afternoon,
Rear Admiral John
Major will be providing an update
on the most recent findings from RV
operations in
search of the Titan submersible.
He will provide a brief statement
and provide the opportunity
for questions after.
Please limit your questions
to one per hour.
Following the briefing,
the Joint Information
Center staff
and I will be here to help you
with any of your further needs.
May I now please
introduce Rear Admiral John McGraw
this morning.
And ROV, a remote operated vehicle
from the vessel Horizon Tech,
discovered the tail
cone of the Titan submersible
approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic
on the seafloor.
The ROV subsequently
found additional debris in consultation
with experts
from within the unified command.
The debris is consistent
with the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination.
We immediately notified the families
on behalf of the United States
Coast Guard
and the entire unified command.
I offer my deepest condolences
to the families
I can only imagine
what this has been like for them.
And I hope that this discovery
provides some solace
during this difficult time.
Additionally, we've been in close contact
with the British
and French counsel general
to ensure that they are fully apprized
and that their concerns
are being addressed.
The outpouring of support
in this highly complex search operation
has been robust
and immensely appreciated.
We are grateful
for the rapid mobilization
and of experts on the undersea
search and rescue.
And we thank all of the agencies
and personnel
for their role in the response.
We're also incredibly grateful
for the full spectrum
of international assistance
that's been provided.
The ROV
will remain
on scene
and continue to gather information.
Again, our most heartfelt condolences
go out to the loved ones of the crew
Well, now take questions.
What are we going to be?
We're going to talk about
the delay in between the first
coming
This was a
incredibly complex case,
and we're still working
to develop the details for the timeline
involved with this casualty
and the response.
And so will provide that.
James Matthews from Sky News.
What other debris have you focused on?
Any trace of
So this is an incredibly complex
operating environment
on the seafloor over two miles
beneath the surface.
And so the no remote operating
vehicle has been searching,
and it is highly capable.
And we've been able to classify parts
of the pressure chamber
for the Titan submersible.
Let me refer to
one of my undersea experts here Mr.
Paul Hankin, to talk about the nature
of some of the debris
Thank you, Admiral.
So essentially, we found out
of five different
major pieces of debris that
told us that it was the
remains of the Titan.
The initial thing we found
was a nose cone
which was outside of the pressure hall.
We then found a large debris field
within that large debris field.
We found the
the front end bell of the pressure hole.
That was the first indication that
there was a catastrophic event
Shortly thereafter, we found the
a second smaller debris field
within that debris field.
We found
the the other end of the pressure hall
to the aft and bell
which was basically that comprised
the totality of that pressure vessel.
We continue to map the debris field.
And as the admiral said, we will
do the best we can to
fully map out what's down there.
Right now.
Thank you very much for that.
It's a it's
a very difficult question to ask,
but it will be an important one
for the families, of course.
But what are the prospects of recovery
So so the questions arise related.
I'm restating the question
from the standpoint
of sometimes it's
hard to hear the question here.
What are the prospects for
recovering crew members?
And so this is a incredibly unforgiving
environment down there on the sea floor.
And the debris is consistent
with a catastrophic
implosion of the vessel.
And so we'll continue to work
and continue to search the area
down there.
But I don't have an answer for prospects
at this time.
Every time a fellow at NBC News
is being sorry.
Any suggestion at all
that the at the shop itself
collided with the wreckage of Titanic
or that instead
it might have imploded above the wreckage
and then rained down nearby?
So the question was,
is there any question as to
whether or not
the sub collided with the Titanic
or whether it imploded above
and debris field created from that.
So the the the location of the Titan
submersible was in an area
that was approximately 600 feet
from the wreck of the Titanic.
I have an expert here that can
that is familiar
with that area and can talk about
the debris field
and what
indicates in terms of the
where the casualty may have occurred
relatively quickly.
Karl, tell me when that
was called back on.
The expert voice is coming up
to answer the question.
Thank you, Admiral.
So the question is,
where does the wreck lie
in relation to the Titanic?
I didn't hear the admiral's answer,
I think. 600 feet.
Was that correct, Admiral?
So that's that's off the bow of Titanic.
It's in an area
where there is not any debris of Titanic.
It is a smooth bottom there.
To my knowledge, in anything
I've seen, there's no Titanic wreckage
in that area.
And again, 200 plus meters from the bow.
And consistent
with the location of last communication
for an implosion in the water column
and the size of the debris field
is consistent
with that implosion in the water column.
Well,
there are
some question
in terms of the timing here.
You say that
this was a catastrophic explosion
and I know it's early on,
but is it your estimation
that this happened
right at the moment
when they lost contact
an hour and 45 minutes after?
So the
question was
about the
timing of the catastrophic implosion
Right now,
it is too early to tell with that.
We know that as we've been prosecuting
this search
over the course of the last 72 hours,
and beyond
that, we've had sonar buoys in the water
nearly continuously and have not detected
any catastrophic events
when those sonobuoys
have been in the water.
So how would you describe
what happens from here, sir,
in the next days and weeks?
We will.
That question was,
what happens from here? What?
What's the next?
Our thoughts are with the families
and making sure that
they have
an understanding
as best as we can provide
of of what happened and begin
to find some closure
in terms of the large process.
We're going to continue to
investigate the
site of the debris field.
And then I know that there's
also a lot of questions about how, why
and when did this happen.
And so, you know, those are questions
that we will collect
as much information as we can on Now,
while the governments are meeting
and discussing, you know, what
an investigation of this nature
of a casualty might look like,
this is something that happened.
I'll just just remind everybody,
this is something that happened
in a remote portion of the ocean with
people from
several different countries
around the world.
And so it is a complex case
to work through,
but I'm confident that
those questions will begin
to get answered
in the U.K..
Is there any suggestion
this time factors mean
anything could have prevented this
to save the five people on board, or
is this quite simply
the.
The question was,
was there any suggestion
that time factors
may have played a
role or
consideration in the casualty here?
And so the debris field
is consistent with a catastrophic
implosion of the vessel.
Again, while we were prosecuting
the search,
we had
listening devices in the water throughout
and did not hear any signs
of catastrophic failure from those.
And so we're going to
continue to investigate
or we're going to continue to document
the information there.
And and understand
based on all the information
we have, the timeline,
not how many in the investigation.
So what does it take for the resources
required for the investigation,
which is going out in
So the question was what
what are the resources
required for the investigation
in which ships will be pulling out
and staying in?
And so it's too early for me
to talk about an investigation.
That's a decision
that's going to be taken outside of
the search and and efforts
that I was leading.
And but we do have a number of vessels.
We have nine vessels on the scene
right now.
We had medical personnel on scene.
We had other technicians on scene.
And so we will begin to demobilize
personnel and vessels from the scene
over the course of the next 24 hours.
But we're going to continue
remote operations on the sea floor.
And and I don't have a timeline for when
we would intend to stop remote operations
on the sea floor at this point.
Admiral, as a result of this,
as a result
of this, do you
think there
should be changes in the way
these are safely rated or inspected
so that this won't happen again?
Yeah.
The question was essentially about
do you think that there should be changes
in safety ratings or inspection
for these standards at
I know that there's a lot of questions
about why, how,
when this happened
and the members of the unified command,
you know,
have those questions
to ask
as professionals and experts that work
in this environment.
And this is an incredibly difficult
and dangerous environment
to work in out there.
But those those questions about
the regulations that apply and
the standards,
that's going to be, I'm sure,
focus on future review.
Right now, we're focused on documenting
the the scene and continuing the
we are trying to
find out there are we
we don't know the timing here,
but there was the banging noises
yesterday that redirected
and we deployed the ROV to this area.
Is there anything
conclusive in those noises?
And to that redirection?
And then finding this debris field today
all help.
So throughout the search efforts,
we reacted to the information
that we had available to us.
And while we continue to send it off for
deeper analysis, again, really complex
operating environment for us to work in.
Let me check with the experts.
But there doesn't appear to be any
connection between the noises and
the location on the seafloor.
Again,
this was a catastrophic
implosion of the vessel,
which would have generated
a significant broadband sound
down there
that the sonobuoys for it have picked up.
This will be the last question
I'm going to ask you about
regarding the family
that dropped
into the ocean today and arrived early,
early this morning at sea,
swiftly was able to find the debris field
by the speed of that.
And also were all of the assets involved
moved as swiftly as possible to the area?
Was any help turned away?
Some lawmakers
This was a incredibly complex operation
and we were able to mobilize
an immense amount of gear to the site in
just a really remarkable amount of time.
Given the fact that we started
without any sort of vessel response
plan for this
or any sort of pre-staged resources
and so the equipment
that was brought on site this morning
that we were using was a pelagic ROV,
capable of operating at 6000 meters.
Camera sonar, other
articulating arms and resources on it.
And it you know,
we had to transport it here through C-17
aircraft.
This is two aircraft
that it took to get this up here.
And so we've really had the right gear
onsite and worked
as us as as swiftly as possible
to bring all of the capabilities
that we had to bear
to this search and rescue effort.
And it was just a huge international
and interagency
effort to make this happen.
So I'm really grateful for all of
the responders
that came out to support this.
And and really
search for
for the vessel.
It is a difficult day for all of us.
And it's especially difficult
for the families.
And our thoughts are with the families
today.
But this was an immense support.
And we had the right gear on the bottom
to to find it
not making it.
Will you attempt to recover the bodies?
Can we ask you about the victims
who may be recovering?
Thank you so much, everyone,
for attending this afternoon.
There are no future
planned press conferences.
Updates will be shared to the
USCG Northeast Twitter page.